[Music]
Jaxson Pierre South Dakota hi jack how
are you how are you better than I
deserve what's up I need to make a deal
with my wife to get on the Dave Ramsey
plan we have no debt she wants a new
house I don't want to go back into debt
to have a new house but she does so she
agreed to get on a budget on the Dave
Ramsey budget if we go back into debt
mm-hmm okay I what do you want me to do
should I do it I wouldn't I think you
got issues that anything to do with
budgets or mortgages
I called marriage I don't know deals
with my wife where we trade off stupid
for smart so she quits being mad at me
well she's not mad it's a compromise
where we're working together I knew she
didn't want to stay in the house we're
in for quite some time so what is your
home currently worth 300 okay and what
does she want to move into pray tell
probably 500 okay and your household
income is 200 how long does it take to
save $200,000 making 200,000 with no
house payment couple years yeah that's
your compromise yes darling you can have
the house we'll have the money together
in two years and you're gonna be on a
budget with me to help us get there
we're not going to spend a dime I'm not
gonna do a whole bunch of stuff I'd like
to do so that I can pay cash with you
for this house you want moving up then
$500,000 house in Prairie aren't Pierre
South Dakota ought to be a freakin
mansion it'd be nice yeah I'd be a
really nice house like what six 8,000
square feet no not like that nice and
it's got some dirt under it then now
okay anyway what that's what Sharon and
I would do we would I would want to buy
her the house that she wants but we're
going to do it in a wise method it is
not unreasonable to wait two years to
pay cash for a house when you make
$200,000
to move up in the house so you do what
you want to do but i wouldn't do it i
don't think that's a compromise i think
it's a stupid decision you got the huge
income you're dead free and she can't
wait two years to bike to pay cash for a
move up in a house of course she can and
that's what we would do at our house you
do what you want to do but that's what
we would do thanks for the call